vous n'y a pas de racisme anti-blancs
donc vikash à mayol n'y a pas de racisme
anti blanc parce que par le délégué a
déjà déjà pourquoi il ya du racisme
pourquoi on doit rajouter en tino et
j'aimerais savoir qui a théorisé ce
racisme anti blanc ça vient de l'extrême
droite évidemment essayer donc je suis
j'imagine
eric zemmour peut-être où je ne suis pas
d'extrême droite alors c'est juste pour
finir c'est loupé j'aimerais nous le
racisme il est expliqué par des gens qui
ont subi hier à 6 lits à hugues martin
luther king james baldwin dias baldwin
il raconte un truc extraordinaire quand
il était aux états unis il a subi le
racisme
donc ils avaient peur ce retour des
iphone une balle dans le dos notamment
des flics parce que c'était très dur à
ségrégation et c est un jouet elle est
venue en france il s'est dit ça y est la
france le pays l'universalisme des
droits de l'homme le pays des lumières
je suis enfin libre la première journée
s'est embarqué par les flics
à partir de ce moment-là ce match et son
mari nicolas batum a fini à saldé c'est
ça la différence c'est que moi quand je
suis noir je ris je vais me faire
contrôler par des visites les bleus
rifai
voilà vous les blancs vous les blancs
les noirs nous demande on demande la
gagner
domination il ya une utilisation à tant
de profits et karim zéribi j'ai
longtemps la planète j'aime pas la
domination
comment ça a été organisé pour nous
utiliser ça semblait regretter ici c'est
le départ assis quand tu fais ici on les
a invités ça ça veut dire que thuram ne
pourra plus jamais combattre le racisme
si vous mettez ça au même plan c'est à
dire que nous nous sommes foutus si nous
combattons tous
thuram et l'a fait c'est sûr elle le
fait à chaque fois on lui dit hier un
racisme anti blanc parce que tu défends
les noirs alors ça veut dire que son
emplacement il acculèrent durant